a man a building a vision this apartment
house is the future of energy supply
Christian upper wants to make homes into
energy suppliers this one has a
photovoltaic array on the roof a
miniature power plant in the basement a
high-performance battery for storage and
electric cars in the driveway the
concept is novel and slowly gaining
momentum I avoid admitting statuscode a
[ __ ] you want to turn the status quo
upside down and do things differently we
want to take coal and nuclear power out
of the energy equation down here the big
plan looks pretty unspectacular this is
the power plant that converts gas into
electricity and heat a few steps away
are the lithium batteries that store
electricity generated by solar panels on
the roof and two electric cars will in
the future be parked here they can be
charged up for free the idea was to
construct an apartment building that
reacts autonomously to weather and
energy prices if there's lots of Sun or
wind the house gets its electricity from
the solar panels or wind energy from the
grid that also charges the batteries and
the cars any leftover energy can be sold
on days where there's little winders Sun
heat and electricity flows from the
batteries to the house but what controls
it all software running at the leash
blick company headquarters in Hamburg
the software gives orders charge the
batteries by electricity crank up the
power plant choices are based on data
like how long the sun's been shining how
topped up the battery is or what
electricity costs at a given moment
given time as a here we collect that
data or we buy it everything flows into
the conductor software either as a
direct input or as a value that it
calculates on its own based on past data
if it knows that the household needed
this much energy yesterday but today is
warmer
colder then it adjusts its prognosis
accordingly and you can also estimate
tomorrow's use walls in this company in
southern Germany manufactures the
battery arrays for systems like these
when it started production three years
ago business was modest but rising
demand has raised output here and pushed
prices down today a battery big enough
for an apartment building costs about
six thousand euros we're experiencing
really explosive growth at the moment
compared to three months ago we now turn
out a month's production in just one
week Mona [ __ ] a top but the batteries
also have to improve developers are
working to improve their efficiency in
capacity in the future energy storage
systems will be key to many new business
models that's in the future households
will network through licks blick or
other organizations to secure a common
electrical supply in other words a
revolution is going to take place with
network systems and communities that are
able in some cases to supply their own
electricity virtual power plants like
these are controversial says Christian
uppit
the unzip it many of our competitors are
casting a critical eye on our activities
they're starting to see that the concept
of large-scale power generation doesn't
have a future it's a conf done without
value the energy sector is in turmoil
and up this company sees an opportunity
but new concepts have to prove
themselves